Stuntman Chad Stahelski is four years younger
than Keanu Reeves and has been performing
stunts for movies and TV since 1993.
Early in his career, he stood in for Brandon
Lee for reshoots of "The Crow" after Lee was
accidentally killed on set.
Stahelski looks a bit like the improbable
love child of Alec Baldwin and George Clooney,
but he got the job doubling for Reeves in
"The Matrix" because his boss on another project
thought the two looked alike.
Whatever you think of their resemblance or
lack thereof, the pair became a solid team.
Stahelski doubled for Reeves again on "The
Replacements," "The Matrix Reloaded," "Constantine,"
and "Thumbsucker."
He also coordinated the martial arts stunts
for "The Matrix Revolutions."
After a long career doing the stunts himself,
Stahelski mostly works as a stunt coordinator now.
However, he's also found time to occupy the
director's chair.
He has directed Reeves in all four "John Wick"
films and has a slate of many more directing
projects in development.